hello and welcome to this video this is
a new rapid game 25 minutes ten second
increment and we'll see what happens
playing RS a or as our if it's a really
German person that is abbreviated some
Joan german term we'll see i'm shooting
for the Greenfeld i'm experimenting with
this a little bit at the moment i really
hope to get some kind of mainline
opening not some london system auditory
or whatever just a bit more interesting
yeah Gugu felt is a really good opening
one of the very few openings that I've
never played a tournament chess always
felt that yeah it's a little bit too
complicated and um yeah and it's too
complicated to play without knowing it
well and has never studied it in much
detail it went for it okay is playing
the Russian system which is one of the
main lines of course let me check one
two check ins five-minute writing
throughout 2000 it's not so bad from
b'ham and every germany by national
rating was nineteen fifty so we have an
idea about his strength 1950 german
national rating is about 2050 USCF if
you want a comparison okay um watch ever
playing now there is a six there's 9 a-6
there is knight c6 various moves and I
don't know it don't know any of them um
yeah a 6b five is currently currently
maybe the mainline 96 however is also
gaining some momentum ha what do what to
play even bishop is six I believe as a
move that has been played recently
asics is really very sharp now it acted
all lines are sharp mm this kind of
comes with the territory okay I'll play
96 the interesting moment is coming if
he goes maybe we should be to waste them
off it's the main move and then black
handle v5 for our pawn sacrifice a 5d
594 or there is Bishop g4 i believe the
pawn sacrifice after Bishop e2e 5595 is
currently hotly debated line on top
level chess in in the January event the
Tata Steel tournament there was a game
between the two chinese players i'm not
mistaken ding ding they run ye where
they had this on the board that we
should be to e5 line but this is this is
what I know we are that is it is
currently discussed but I don't know any
details if white plays the move d5 here
Black is going for night f5 I believe h3
yeah this is this is also also move for
sure Bishop g4 he wants to prevent okay
um so what is happening 'if i vas sister
the obvious choice now bust open the
center the e5 d 594 is a lot stronger in
comparison to Bishop e2 as after a 5d
594 90 xt4 point XD for Queen takes d4
there is night XD for black immediately
wins it's a needle tactic 5d take c 597
esox night eggs if a 95 looks dangerous
for white looks like a big big
development yeah so I'm going to play a
five-night xe5 i think is probably very
bad do tonight XD form after d takes d5
I just recognized that I don't have to
play 97 I can also play Bishop to e6
intermediate move attacking the Queen
and only then play Knight f6 to d7 to
regain the pawn that's probably even
better now he will probably play that
though d 594 looks looks really wrong
okay maybe can play that and play like
d5 9423 or something like that it
doesn't look particularly convincing but
might still might still happen ok nitey
force is clear him threatening on john c
2 now he has to play Queen d3 I think I
think this is the only move now Queen a
for many who
even though it doesn't make much sense
to play this you have to currency to
taking on default not playable at all
94a for Queen d4 Knight takes e4 is the
tactic so yeah yes you go queen bee
three that's pretty much clear but what
to do then with black now c6 looks most
logical even though night xe5 is
certainly yeah I certainly move to
consider that Queen d3c 695 m
oh not easy at all okay if he goes
cleaned III do I have some simpler
solution might take their three Queen
takes yeah well this is playable but it
doesn't feel much yeah that doesn't feel
a lot like like being in the spirit of
the gruene felt I really like to keep
that knight on d4 it is such an annoying
peace making it difficult for him to
develop I'm a bit surprised that he's
not has not moved yet because Queen a4 I
mean that looks wrong somehow going into
even more tempe with Bishop d7 so queen
bee three is kind of the only move
anyway or screen d3 is there some kind
of draw back then I don't see 97
something that that comes into
consideration 495 possibly f5 okay now
he has plated
the difference here between age three
and Bishop b2 is by the way then with
the bishop on e2 white can take on d 490
4424 the e-file is closed okay what to
do now as I said c6 it's this is
actually what i would like to play
busting open everything even more but
night xe5 I'm not sure about
maybe I can play that like rook e8 Queen
takes d4 and then yeah it's it's
dangerous clearly dangerous I can i take
c 4 then also but
see 695
yeah ninety-five looks very risky but
knight on d4 is hanging him it really is
c6 night XD five night XD five is that a
move Quinn txt for this one doesn't feel
convincing okay if I go for this for
possible f5 and 95 I don't want to
invest more time this should be 60 ever
a bishop III I mean maybe
and I'd really like a move 97 to be
honest now that i have played it Bishop
e3 looks looks like a move for him
now maybe I should have thought a little
bit harder trying to make c6 work
because that really was the move that
was in spirit of the position I was
reflecting the spirit of the position um
best so yeah I don't know f5 there this
is the this was the idea ok yeah tweenty
tweenty forum this is skinning maybe not
right away but the idea gets to be part
of the the position now for example
castles knights e5 they might be quincy
form
ok this is nothing that I mind
yeah an opening like the Guru felt has a
real advantage in practical play over
more let's say I'm yeah it's a classical
or traditional if you want openings like
the Queen's temple gambit declined or so
for example um the price of each move is
a lot higher now you can cannot really
play second rate moves that much with
white in an opening like the Queens
gambit sometimes why it gets away with
playing them 102 yeah less precise moves
and still has some kind of equal game
often and the group file that's a bit
difficult there are mostly quite sharp
lines and to play anything that is not
completely spot-on will lead to trouble
in most cases and we'll see what he
comes up with him castles knights e5
looks good I thank you for for black
yeah castles he just canceled so I
thought 95 even though mmm this is of
course um rather complicated business
okay so 95 but I don't really see the
problem yeah and it's a little bit
difficult to play and play play a
different move anyway so let's go for it
so Quincy form there is Knight takes e4
that's night ext2 if we start with night
XD to like Quincy 492 Queenie to every
494 25 so this will be a win over porn
huh I don't know Quincy 494 is a little
bit more ambitious maybe Knight takes e4
is there a drawback d6 check there's
always specially six this is not not a
big issue yeah I think I'll take on you
for with the night currently don't see a
problem with it nine txt 20 ever also
was promising
yeah 86 check we should be six it's not
so clear what is what he does now night
XD 484 I mean this just looks like I'm
material up maybe it's still 90 for
takes and then some d6 at least they
don't have Bishop b6 them with the tempo
and reply
yeah okay so yeah actually I could
transpose with night xe2 to the line
that we hella mentioned earlier 92
killeen TX fe 4 but now the Queen can
capture ok so I wanted to take here
anyway ok now you know Nana have be five
now i have p 5 now that should be a big
problem and it's not let's not be too
too quick him but after b5 he doesn't
have a square for the queen that step
protect c2 yeah okay it was one reason
why i didn't want to take on e2 so early
i wanted to have this or keep in many
cases this night for her tactics no
that's it
yeah so again that what was decided on
probably will be decided quite early but
it still had a very interesting opening
opening play
yeah I'm kind of making it sound like
the game is over I just hope it is I
mean if i take it to i'll take you
towards check and then even take see one
so he has difficulties keeping even the
night on g5 and where is the Queen
actually going to see 5 or to be four
just both both it's not looking very
attractive lc5 night Teague's chick
takes you one Queen take special 86 I
just lose the house
the move age three that he played on on
on move aid is probably not so critical
even though it shouldn't be too yeah
such a disastrous outcome quite resigned
okay so let's have a look down as a man
you this is the most popular movement
here the movie 5d 594 is a different
different kind of animal because here i
don't have Knight takes e4 black plays C
six-year d6 and then Ruby aid which is
very sharp like this this this is what I
remember roughly from from this ding
Liren why he game something like that
but I think even CC pawn got sacrificed
in that game yeah this is probably a
little bit more testing even though h3
is yeah it's probably not terribly bad
or anything it just feels a little bit
slow ok Wendy 5 and he played d5 and
this is already probably slightly
questionable um like ticks yeah I know
it's interesting i have bishop is 60 i
have ninety-seven i was thinking 97
mostly but this also should be a
possible a team okay the computer wants
to sec the queen it's probably right
that's probably good for what three
minor pieces and black has lost his dark
squared bishop okay so my original oops
sorry I'm original intention of playing
this is better the point is that this
will lead to a very strong compensation
check as I saw this and felt like this
should be enough compensation
probably take sticks and now the Queen
somewhere to be three now maybe 93 yen
the aplex development is pretty pretty
strong it I think it should be enough to
compensate for a pawn if you just go for
the check here for example black is
threatening to take take a form which is
mean it's not the dream scenario that we
want to put the V take on c3 but this
feels like some kind of exit strategy if
more ambitious things fail certainly
interesting ok but this now fields
fields did feel too tricky and I missed
something brilliant he actually wow wow
the computer finds Knight takes e4 which
is really strong Wow no I didn't think
about that move at all which is really
this is a killer blow yeah Queen takes
this Bishop f5 and this is pretty clear
so night has to take and then f5 wow
that's very strong efore is coming
before is coming something like this is
looking disastrous and yeah something
like this going to take it with tempo
and the decisive attack White has no
development here absolutely no wow this
is a super strong move Knight takes and
five the engine gives this as the
relatively best continuation like power
making like a desperado here and then
play play this position right why these
two pawns down even though this is not a
great structure but still it's two pawns
oh because that was a lot stronger I
played a play des which is a super lame
in comparison I tried to make c6 work
but I couldn't really see what to do
here again i take c 4 wow I didn't see
that move at all night XD 5 I was
thinking about but Knight takes e4 most
on my agenda door yeah this is yeah this
is quite clear that strong Knight takes
also strong and here I'm threatening
Bishop g5 and why this getting killed
he's got no development now I mean this
is in the group felt if you play five
Queen moves and hive Queen moves and
then like 6.45 pawn moves in the first
13 it's not going to stand I take before
okay then it's e6 also move of course in
all pales in comparison to Knight takes
e4 which is just crushing but still okay
so this was played and f5 yeah i mean
the computer at least gives me an edge
but it's not a computer wants to start
with this okay then f5 okay this and
then at five yeah maybe maybe that maybe
ma'am more promising this is what the
engine is giving yeah i was thinking of
that i have multiple i mean i thought i
thought more than one good move him even
taking where the porn seems to be okay i
think this is very sharp
I've got very good dynamics going in my
favor like T 3 and so on from a
structural point of view black looks
little bit we add but now it i played
this and this is probably leading into
trouble b6 is given by the computer
that's also move that I've briefly
thought about but then I was too tempted
by clarifying the situation does this
losses this losers already will be 54
stronger haha the best line is this
check no Bishop to the one threatening
Bishop b3 Wow nice move with the
computer
this is the line that the engine is
giving check with equality yeah I've got
a pawn and the bishop pair and while
this is strong yeah no idea stop bridges
on equal so here b5 was for stronger
adds more forcefully queen I mean
doesn't have many squares and it's a
kind of comparable load yet in the game
this this though yeah okay here this
losses but he could have check continued
with this at least I exists what I
expected and but I felt I should be
better and I'll just develop stuff here
so those pawns it's not a totally clear
fair anyway six points Queen age four
yeah i mean the computer is giving me
about a pawn here but the position is
very murky so kind of anything could
have happened situation okay yeah in the
game this happened and after b5 while
it's just completely overloaded i will
lose at least peas yeah i hope you
enjoyed the game thanks for watching